It's been 16 years since Keanu Reeves put
down his leather duster and sunglasses as
he walked away from his role as Neo in The
Matrix trilogy.
But now that he's returning to the familiar
dystopian universe to become "The One" once
again in The Matrix 4, he's sharing his thoughts
on the new film.
Chatting with Entertainment Tonight, Reeves
spoke up about the script for the fourth Matrix
film, which was officially announced in August
2019.
As Reeves walked the red carpet for Semper
Fi, the upcoming British drama film produced
by his sister Karina Miller, he told ET that
he'd read the script for The Matrix 4.
"Are you happy about where Neo is at?
"Yeah, no, absolutely. It's very ambitious as it should be!"
Admittedly, there isn't a lot to go on with
Reeves' comments, but it's still thrilling
to hear that he's getting pumped up about
returning to one of his many career-defining
roles.
Plus, "ambitious" is definitely an interesting
word considering that the original Matrix
trilogy changed the sci-fi movie genre, ultimately
defining an entire era of action sequences,
special effects, and world-building.
Thought very little is known about The Matrix
4 yet, we do know that the film is set to
push even more boundaries and deliver insightful,
incisive, and interesting commentary on our
current society.
As Lana Wachowski noted when announcing The
Matrix 4, the ideas that she and her sister
Lilly explored 20 years ago with the first
film are even more relevant now.
When the first Matrix film hit theaters in
1999, audiences were blown away by the extraordinarily
intricate world which presented a reality
that wasn't actually real.
The world everyone thought they were living
in was revealed to be a computer simulation
created by machines that humans tried to overpower;
everything in this fake "reality" is created
for humans by those computers.
When he's given the chance to escape the Matrix
and learn the truth, Neo sees the dark real
world where the sun is blotted out and humans
must survive by hiding from the machines both
inside and outside of the Matrix itself.
In the end, it turns out Neo is "The One,"
a fated hero who can actually control the
Matrix while within the simulation, thereby
being the only person who has any hope of
stopping the machines in their tracks.
After The Matrix: Reloaded was released in
2003, the trilogy seemed like it came to a
definitive end with The Matrix: Revolutions,
which hit theaters later that same year.
At the conclusion of Revolutions, Neo sacrifices
himself to save humanity and bring an end
to the human and machine conflict.
With a conclusion that final, it seems strange
that Reeves could possibly return for a fourth
installment.
But we know that both Reeves and Carrie Anne-Moss
are firmly aboard The Matrix 4 and will reprise
their roles as characters who were last seen
dying, so clearly the minds behind the new
film found a way to resurrect Neo and Trinity.
Reeves has certainly kept busy in the years
since he last played Neo.
After appearing in various romantic comedies
as well as Richard Linklater's adaptation
of A Scanner Darkly, he produced a documentary
entitled Side by Side and earned his first
directing credit on the underrated Man of
Tai Chi.
However, thanks to two stuntmen from the original
Matrix films, Reeves returned to his action
roots in 2014 with John Wick, which ended
up becoming its own trilogy.
Alongside these butt-kicking projects, Reeves
has taken the time to appear in some comedic
projects as well.
He starred in Destination Wedding and made
self-parodying cameos in the Netflix original
films Always Be My Maybe and Between Two Ferns:
The Movie.
He may have bounced around genres since the
Matrix trilogy wrapped, but Reeves has planted
himself firmly in the pop culture canon with
his recent film appearances.
There's truly no better time than now for
a Reeves-led Matrix 4, and we can't wait to
see what it's like.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.